ein verbrechen das uns noch in den
knochen steckt das so fünf monate etwa
zurückliegt im januar ende januar der
polizistenmord von kusel eigentlich bloß
eine verkehrskontrolle doch dann wird
geschossen getötet eine junge
polizeianwärterin jasmin und der
oberkommissar sterben kaltblütig
erschossen hingerichtet von einem mann
der sonst wird tötet gleich beginnt der
prozess gegen den wilderer der zum
polizistenmörder wurde
andreas s er ist bei seiner tat offenbar
noch brutaler vorgegangen weil es
anfangs schienen
erbarmungslos hat er mit einer
schrotflinte die beiden polizeibeamten
jasmin b und alexander k erschossen
ermittler sprechen von anfang an von
einer grausamen hinrichtung im verdacht
steht zunächst auch der 33 jährige
florian v der in der tat nach dabei war
wir treffen ihn mit frau und kind in
seinem heimatort an doch reden will er
mit uns nicht gegen ihn wird noch
anklage wegen wilderei und versuchter
strafvereitlung erhoben er befindet sich
auf freiem fuß am tatort erinnert nicht
mehr viel an das grausame verbrechen das
war genau hier und diese schreckliche
tat geschah und hier steht jetzt ein
kreuz und blühen um an die gestorbenen
polizisten zu erinnern rückblick die
beamten der polizeiinspektion kusel sind
am 31 januar auf einer routinemäßigen
streifenfahrt als sie an den wagen auf
der kreisstraße 22 in ulm at anhalten
andreas es ist gerade dabei mit einem
freund tierkadaver in sein fahrzeug
einzuladen als ihn die beamten antreffen
und auffordern sich auszuweisen statt
jedoch dann den jagdschein herauszuholen
name eine schrotflinte und schoss ihr
unvermittelt ins gesicht
darauf der name ein jagdgewehr mit
nachtsichtgerät und ging um den
baum herum und fing an auf den anderen
polizisten alexander kahr zu schießen er
hatte keine chance es war dunkel der
jäger war ein sehr guter schütze und
schoss ihn firma in die hüfte und einmal
in den kopf dann bemerkt er dass die
junge polizistin noch lebt geh zu ihr
wird sie auf den rücken und schießt ihr
eiskalt ins gesicht als die
herbeigerufene verstärkung nur wenige
minuten später eintrifft sind die beiden
polizisten tot
wenig später kommt man den tätern auf
die spur die beiden männer werden
verhaftet bei den kollegen pures
entsetzen seit gestern morgen um 422
gilt für unser polizeipräsidium hier in
kaiserslautern eine neue zeitrechnung
wir sind alle schockiert zutiefst
entsetzt und traurig über den tod
unserer 24 jährigen kollegin und unseres
29 jährigen kollegen inzwischen ist
bekannt andreas s hatte 2020 mit seiner
bäckerei insolvenz anmelden müssen und
einen schuldenberg von 2,4 millionen
angehäuft das mutmaßliche motiv doppel
mord zur verdeckung einer straftat und
möglicherweise habgier offenbar löste
andreas es das leben der beiden jungen
polizisten aus nur um seine illegale
wilderei fortsetzen zu können und
am landgericht in kaiserslautern ist
jetzt unsere kollegin lisa dudley st
dieser mann hier ist für immer
weggesperrt
nun das ist auf jeden fall was die
angehörigen der opfer hoffen und auch
alle anderen beteiligten natürlich dass
dieser mann für immer hinter gitter
kommt das ist ja nicht sein erstes
verbrechen worum es jetzt natürlich geht
es wird das nur eine burg eine
lebenslange haftstrafe oder gibt es auch
noch eine besondere schwere der schuld
bzw eine sicherungsverwahrung so dass er
noch 15 oder 25 jahren nicht rauskommen
kann schilder uns was über die
atmosphäre dort heute am gericht nach
diesem schrecklichen polizistenmord
dieser auch so jungen polizisten deren
angehörige sind die heute dort schauen
die dem täter in die augen
die rechtsbeistände der angehörigen die
haben schon vor einigen tagen mitgeteilt
dass die familien nicht zum prozess
kommen werden der grund ist dass im
prozess natürlich die taten in allen
details noch einmal erläutert werden
müssen da werden gutachter aussagen da
wird über den tatort geredet da wird in
jedem detail noch mal erklärt und
durchgegangen werden wie dieses
schreckliche verbrechen abgelaufen ist
und da haben die restbestände den
familien geraten nicht zu kommen weil
das retro matti sie rennt wirkt die
familie von jasmin baby soll sogar in
einer kur seien derzeit damit sie so
wenig wie möglich von diesem prozess
mitbekommen das ist zu schmerzhaft für
die angehörigen durch diesen prozess
durch diese bilder nochmal durch zu
müssen diese fördert mit den ersten
informationen zum ersten prozesstag